ضمن عمليه المخلب السيف لا تلبس طائره
حربيه تركيه منذ فجر الاحد الا وتوجه
ضرباتها ضد المقاتلين الاكراد في سوريا
والعراق وبعد مرور ايام على غارات طالت
عشرات المواقع في مناطق نفوذ القوات
الكرديه اعربت الولايات المتحده عن قلقها
العميق ازاء الاعمال العسكريه الاخيره
التي تهدد استقرار المنطقه حيث حد الناطق
باسمي وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه على ضروره
وقف فوري للتصعيد مضيفا انه واشنطن تتفهم
ان لدى انقره مخاوف امنيه لكنه اكد ان
عملياتها اثرت بشكل مباشر على سلامه
العسكريين في المنطقه اما وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه فاكدت ان الاحداث التي يشهدها
العراق وشمال سوريا تهدد مهمه التصدي
لتنظيم داعش على جانبي الحدود
وبينما طقس في تركيا بلا هواده يخشى اكراد
سوريا ان تغض سلطات النظام السوري عنهم
الطرف فهي لم تبدي موقفا ضربات المتواصله
واكتفت بذكري عدد القتلى بلا تعليق اخر
حتى الان لا تبدو ملامح العلاقه بين تركيا
والنظام واضحه فالمحللون يتوقعون بان
القطيعه التي استمرت 11 سنه قد تتبدد
تدريجيا خلال المرحله المقبله اي تماما
حينما شبت الاحتجاجات في مارس عام 2010
عندما كانت النقطه الفارقه التي قلبت
العلاقه بينهما قبل ذلك كانت تركيا حليفا
لسوريا حديثا اقتصاديه سياسيا اساسيا
لسوريا والصداقه بين بشار الاسد ورجب طيب
اردوغان كانت في اوجهها
الان انا الاوان لان يعود هذا التقارب
بحسب محللين سياسيين رجحوا ان هناك مؤشرات
تقارب بين الطرفين بواسطه روسيه عدا عن
تصريح اردوغان الاخير بان احتمال لقاء
الاسد لم يعد مستبعدا قائلا الا مجال
للنقمه في السياسه في نهايه المطاف
[موسيقى]